hello yeah we've come to um to join the
ukrainian
army or whatever they're called they're
not even sure of the army's name but
they're utterly convinced of the cause
this is leon from surrey they look like
they need help
we're young strong fit men we can help
so why not outside ukraine's embassy in
london a steady stream of men come to
find out how they can join up to fight
you can send
email a letter for this address yeah and
he contacted you and said what you must
do okay
brian from kent used to be in the
territorial army and you're prepared to
go to ukraine and fight yeah i can get
on the flight tomorrow and if you don't
know i'm asking how old are you
i'm 60 which means i'm just about within
the rain age range they'll accept
we see people from the uk poland hungry
and beyond the seeds of a volunteer army
to fight against the russians
you're iranian and you want to join up
to fight for ukraine why do you want to
do that
because i hate putting i'd like to take
like a pocket knife or stove war waits
for no one and by mid-afternoon
conscious they need to move fast we
catch up again with leon and his friend
tom who also plans to travel to ukraine
which protects your chest
by now they've got hold of some old kit
borrowed from a friend who's an
ex-marine
he does want it back so that's how we
make it back alive so i can give it back
to it as soon as you get on
to get off the train in ukraine your
life is on the line you you're not
guaranteed to make it back especially
not in one piece have you told your
family our family are upset obviously
it's a hard time but
if i'm this scared and this apprehensive
and what are the people over there going
through neither of these men have any
military experience tom runs a dog care
business
are you
afraid uh of course i am i think i would
be silly if i wouldn't be afraid it's
not just volunteer fighters joining
ukraine's war effort supporters are
gathering donations to send to ukraine
essentials for civilians and the front
line i'm extremely proud of our nation
i'm extremely proud that we inspire
other people to come and help us out
those guys are awesome i mean i we need
all support we can get in the uk
communities are coming together to help
ukraine in any way they can issa holland
sky news